a container ship is Back at Sea after
being trapped in the Ukrainian Port of
Odessa since Russia's Invasion 18 months
ago the Joseph Schulte is heading to
Turkey after leaving Ukrainian Waters it
is the first merchant ship to sell from
Odessa since the collapse of the Black
Sea grain deal with Russia last month
the Hong Kong registered vessel sailed
along what Ukraine describes as a new
and temporary humanitarian Corridor for
merchant ships
from Odessa in southern Ukraine
it's exactly one month since the grain
deal collapse in Russia pulled out and
now a commercial vessel has successfully
passed the test and sailed from the
Odessa Port through the Black Sea it's
about to arrive somewhere today in
turkey and this was a test of Ukraine's
so-called humanitarian Corridor they're
really Keen to resume exports and
especially grain exports but this ship
was carrying other cargo there are also
other cargo ships still stranded here in
the ports in Ukraine but this test
doesn't mean that the grain exports now
can resume because there are a lot of
other concerns the cost the insurance
that is involved of exporting from the
Odessa Port so so far the exporters are
saying we're not sending any Grain on
this same humanitarian Corridor maybe
they want to wait and see how the other
ships next after this one that now has
sailed uh how that will go only three
days ago we saw that that Russian
warship has entered commercial vessel on
its way to Ukraine so there's still a
lot of security concerns so meanwhile
grain is still being exported through
the Danube ports but those were also
attacked only last two nights ago step
fans and Al Jazeera in Odessa